all right everybody let's get to this
week's mailbag an increasingly popular
segment people seem to be loving this
segment other than the people who hate
it and that's about
i don't know judging from my email it's
not a zero it's a non-zero number of
people no but the we keep getting more
and more emails and interesting things
so
let's just get right into it first
message from moose
moose says mr pakman sir
while eating lunch in the teachers
lounge today i overheard some coaches
discussing the new vaccine in china with
a 58 fatality rate the conversation
quickly went into one of the coaches
telling everyone china's working on a
vaccine to get rid of our sight and
hearing because they already created
kovid which damaged our taste and smell
i long blinked and face palm what are
your thoughts
obviously it's all bonkers but what's
interesting about that
is
they
seem to concede covid was created to
damage our taste and smell
so now they're going to make a vaccine
to get rid of our sight and hearing but
i thought the problem with covid was the
vaccine not the virus i thought the
point was the vaccine kills you
as you can see there are various
conspiracy theories that covid was
created to take away our damn to damage
our taste and smell
but that the vaccine which prevents that
for many people actually is what kills
you but then now they're going to do a
new quote vaccine
in order to take take people's sight and
hearing it's all completely incoherent
it's all absolute and complete nonsense
it doesn't make any sense and yet this
type of stuff keeps spreading i wonder
where moose
maybe moose is a sign that moose is in
you know some part of the country with
with moose and
that's where you got a lot of teachers
who believe this stuff i don't know it
would be interesting to know what school
district that is but those those people
are teaching some of your kids
some of your kids are being taught
by those folks that is horrifying that
is absolutely and completely horrifying
next email is from bill
bill says
ask this question
does steve scalise believe that his own
election was legitimate
same ballots same election yeah this is
something i pointed out
i think it was in december
which is you've got all these people
saying the results of the presidential
election were bogus bogus can't be
trusted their fake fraud whatever
but all of the other races on the same
ballots like the senators and the
members of congress and all that stuff
those are fine
how exactly did they pull that off and
that would have been this is a reference
to the interview that chris wallace did
with steve scalise that we looked at
last week where chris wallace was saying
did trump win or was it stolen from him
did trump win was it stole from you know
all this type of stuff
did biden win or was it stolen from him
and steve scalise basically answered the
question three or four different ways
none of which were actually direct
answers a great question would be
were there also the same degree of
irregularities and possible fraud in
your election steve scalise because you
were on those same ballots and i don't
know what he would say
that he'd probably have some kind of
work around would be by my prediction
next email is from chase chase says
david audits are okay
why not allow all those demanding audits
to have their way but first they have to
agree to some requirements number one
they must cover all audit expenses
including for experienced objective
observers two counting must be done in
publicly viewed areas
another number two must agree to no
access to personal voter information nor
voter machine tampering
and number three which is really number
four if they find verifiable significant
fraud then the taxpayers will reimburse
all reasonable expenses this would force
them to put up or shut up it sort of
would chase but the problem is that they
would they would still
uh fundraise for it so we
as they've been doing and trump was able
to raise tens of millions saying we're
gonna use this money to fight voter
fraud and the like
so i don't really know
that that would be
the solution to bogus audits the the
bigger issue is what does it even really
mean to do an audit
um and that's a word that's often used
which has different meanings
or no meaning at all
depending on where it's taking place and
so i think it's a bigger systemic
problem but i don't disagree that saying
you've got to pay
uh
is a good idea
in some cases they have paid or at least
they funded the process themselves it
hasn't really deterred too much but
certainly there should be a financial
disincentive from doing this unless
they you know really really believe it
which many of them i know don't
um it could serve to dissuade some of
this nonsense behavior next email today
is from adrian
adrian writes in about autocracy fascism
and republicans
and says i watch your channel i watch
tyt and others i also occasionally look
at the opposite views to give myself
perspective smart thing to do i'm
becoming more and more worried about
2022 and 2024. we've become rather
comfortable in our post in our world
post world war ii but should we can we
say for sure that a new nazi party will
never happen again look at the grand old
party meaning the republican party and
those within it who have always been
there but due to trump and his rhetoric
now feel
they have the license to spout their
true nature as if it was commonplace
should make those of us with any
semblance of decency shudder with fear
yeah this this is a good point and i've
said many times before
anybody who who has the idea
x can never happen or x can never happen
again
needs to rethink that and be more
cautious hopefully certain things won't
happen or won't happen again but listen
you know when trump said at the state of
the union a couple of times we will
never be a socialist country
maybe we will
um unpredictable things happen and how
trump can say the u.s will never be
socialist what about in 100 years what
about 500 years we don't know that and
much the same way for people who say
nazism hitler stuff could never happen
again
assuming it couldn't
is part of what could allow it to and
that's why all of this
drama and delusion
related to the january six riots and the
slow-motion coup that now is being
discussed more and more
cannot be ignored should not be ignored
um and that's part of why we continue to
talk about it andrew wrote in about the
microchip shortage
and says sirs so much has been made of
the current microchip shortage and i
can't believe the nonsense that is being
spread misinformation about shipping
issues and this is satire by the way and
manufacturing backlogs is reaching
ridiculous proportions it's very simple
every vaccine has a microchip
and now every booster will have one as
well
this is why there is a microchip
shortage wake up sheeple
it's sad
but even though i'm telling you this is
satire
i will get comments just if you're if
you're watching this on youtube right
now look down below
you'll see comments that don't realize
that that's satire it's satire it's a
joke it's poking fun at the
disinformation anti-vaxxers all right
everybody relax it's just satire trust
me it's satire
lukian wrote in
lukian says
david
you've been repeatedly accused
of being quote bought by big pharma this
is of course unsubstantiated nonsense
an interesting response i believe could
be for you to share the following
stories
of how youtubers around the world are
being paid to promote anti-vaxx
conspiracies which is literally the
opposite of what you are accused of yeah
without evidence and without even
plausibility people accuse me of being
in the pocket of big pharma i'm getting
money from big pharma to promote the
vaccine now all i've ever done is report
the data and the statistics on vaccine
studies
but there actually are
anti-vaccine influencers and money
floating around to them
to question the efficacy of the vaccines
to promote alternative treatments as if
they are iron clad treatments for covid
on and on and on that's actually where
the money is why would anyone pay me to
quote promote a vaccine
the data says it really protects you
from serious illness and death
we see the overwhelming number of deaths
among the unvaccinated i really went and
got the vaccine nobody paid me to go and
get it
uh why would anyone pay me to promote
the vaccine it doesn't make any sense
nor is there evidence that people are
being paid to promote it there is
evidence people are being paid to
promote
anti-vax ideas
sometimes it's soft anti-vaxxerism which
is talking about
disproportionately focusing on side
effects
or talking about there's plenty of
alternative treatments etc sometimes
it's straight-up anti-vaxx like
conspiracy theory microchip 5g
your arm gets magnetized sort of stuff
there's a combination of both they're
the ones that we know some of whom have
gotten paid next email i love these
oh david you lie so much
it's scary
no wonder your channel is dying i really
love these
because it's so not true and it angers
them that the channels aren't dying we
actually had last week this is i don't
even know why this is happening
we had the best week last week for the
audio podcast
since the week of the insurrection
you've got to go back 10 and a half
months
for a week where we had
the same number of audio podcast
downloads as last week the audio podcast
has been exploding we have more
subscribers than ever on youtube we
reached 1.4 million i'm really excited
about getting to 1.5 million
uh we had something like 30 million
youtube views last month
extremely healthy number um and these
folks have been around for a long time
oh you're circling the drain
any day now you're going to have you're
going to be down to zero viewers
the show has never been bigger and it's
a really exciting thing to see all right
one last bonus message this one's from
facebook's
this one
is from an unnamed an individual whom i
shall not name
who says you need to stop pushing lies
you're accusing this woman of lying you
were the liar the vaccine has not been
approved
you might as well move to venezuela or
nazi germany if that's what you think i
think it would be best for you to shut
up
not a single
punctuation mark not a single well i
guess the apostrophe in your and that's
count
not a single comma
not a single period
just
a run-on
this is the run-on from hell i guess is
what i would say
um and it's kind of funny also
venezuela
or nazi germany both regimes which i
oppose
for different reasons
and which have
very little
in common with each other
sad stuff
sad stuff my friends
get your emails in for the mailbag info
davidpakman.com info davidpakman.com but
and this is a really serious thing
please don't email us every day
please don't email us multiple times a
day
there are now probably about 50 people
in the audience
who relentlessly email us every single
day about things related to politics and
things not related to politics
if you're doing that we almost certainly
are not seeing your emails when we see
someone does this stuff emailing in a
dozen times a day sometimes more um and
they clog our inbox it really restricts
our ability to go through and find
substantive material so we those are
getting filtered directly into the trash
and just just think
am i emailing david every day am i
emailing david multiple times a day
if you are
i we're not seeing we're almost
certainly not seeing the messages
because they're just being auto filtered
we just we just can't keep up with that
it's not what the mailbag and what the
email address is set up for you know
it's
let's let's uh let's be sensible my
friends let's be sensible email is info
davidpakman.com
we have a phenomenal bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpackman.com to get
instant access and we've got a whole new
week of shows coming up for you next
week as well